>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Roberto Salazar: Good
afternoon and welcome
to the Library of Congress.
Today's program is
presented by the Office
of Equal Employment Opportunity and
Diversity Programs formerly known
as the Office of Opportunity
Inclusiveness and Compliance,
with the support of the Office of
the Chief of Staff who's represented
by the Office -- and the Chief
of Staff Mr. [Inaudible].
Thank you for being here.
Today's guest speaker is the founder
and the chief learning officer
of Cook Ross Incorporated, a
consulting firm whose mission is
to provide powerful solutions to
organizations around the world
in the areas of diversity,
inclusion, cultural competence,
leadership development and
organizational change management.
He's one of the nation's
leading diversity consultants
and a nationally-recognized
expert on diversity leadership
and organizational change.
He is the author of the book,
Everyday Bias, Identifying
and Navigating Unconscious
Judgments in Our Daily Lives .
His book in hardcover
will be available for sale
after today's presentation
for a cost of $30.
It will be available at
the table by the entrance.
His other works include
ReInventing Diversity,
Transforming Organizational
Community to Strengthen People,
Purpose, and Performance .
He received his undergraduate degree
from the University of Maryland
and pursued postgraduate studies
in administration, management
and organizational development
at Wheelock College in Boston.
He can be heard on NPR on the
first Monday of every month at noon
as a regular guest of
the Kojo Nnamdi Show.
Please join me in welcoming
our guest, Howard J. Ross.
[ Applause ]
>> Howard Ross: Hi, everybody.
Good afternoon.
I'm going to actually start
with a little video clip.
>> [Background Music] He's the boss.
She's bossy -- the negative way.
Women are perceived at
the office in a new ad
for Pantene that's gone viral.
It's hit a nerve so we
set out to find the truth.
Are women who act exactly the
same as men seen differently?
Listen to this woman.
How do you feel about
her as a job candidate?
>> I know the Windows operating
systems like the back of my hand.
No problem.
>> Now, listen to him.
>> I know the Windows operating
systems like the back of my hand.
No problem.
>> The candidates in
these videos are actors
in a Yale University
hiring experiment.
The resumes identical,
the interviews identical.
>> I'm extremely good at
sizing up people quickly
and delegating responsibility
accordingly.
>> The only difference is gender but
when it comes to who got the job?
>> I thought the male applicant
had better soft skills.
I'd say the woman was
arrogant and over-selling.
>> In hundreds of evaluations,
the female job seekers come off
as more aggressive,
are rated less likeable
and they're less likely to be hired.
>> Isn't it a Catch 22?
You're supposed to be
strong to get that job.
And you're saying if you're
too strong, you won't get it.
>> You need to behave in
this dominant way to advance
as a woman in the workplace.
But you're seen negatively
because that's not how we
expect women to behave.
>> And if you think this is
just male bias, it's not.
Both men and women doing the
hiring made the same call.
>> I think there's a level
of arrogance that becomes --
that might be okay to be a manager
but then there's a step above
and I thought she was
slightly above that.
>> So let's talk and when we
revealed our study results --
>> I was surprised by my reaction.
>> What does that say about us?
>> We've a long way to go.
>> Howard Ross: Yeah, we do
have a long way to go, don't we?
We don't have to go far from the
morning's news each day to see
that we still have a long way to go.
And you know, we look at
circumstances like this
and of course, the first
question that comes
to mind is a question
of equity and justice.
You know, how can people
be successful
if they're not treated fairly
simply because of gender or race
or any other distinction?
And there's another -- excuse me --
another important question
too which is how are we going
to possibly make decent
talent management choices
if we're making them based on things
we don't even know are manipulating
our minds?
And so I want to start this
afternoon by saying, you know,
"I don't care what
your politics are."
You know, I don't care whether
you're a Democrat or a Republican.
I don't care whether
you see yourselves
as liberal or conservative.
And that's something
we might talk over --
talk about over lunch although these
days, people are afraid to talk
about those things over lunch.
What I want to talk about
is how does this dynamic,
this unconscious way
we make decisions
about people impact the essence
of who we are as human beings,
at our jobs, at work,
on the streets?
How does it impact people's
lives, their livelihoods?
And it's not, we know because
most people wake up in the morning
and say, "Hmm, how can I
suppress the people of color
in my organization today?"
How can I hold down
the women, you know?
I'm not saying there aren't
some people like that.
Of course, we know there's some
but overwhelmingly the issue
that we deal with especially
in organizations like yours,
especially in organizations where
we have a relatively highly educated
workforce and, you know, people
who are committed to be a part
of a larger organization --
it rarely shows up that way.
Something else is going on and it's
something that if we tell the truth,
each of us has experienced.
I remember I was down
-- two years ago,
I was down at the Jackson
State University in Jackson,
Mississippi doing some work for
a couple of days with the deans
and the faculty members down there.
And I had to fly from there to
New York City for another client
so I had to go through
Memphis, Tennessee.
And I got to Memphis in
time for my last flight out.
And as soon as I get through the
gate, the gate attendant comes on
and says, "Ladies and gentlemen,
there'll be a 45-minute delay."
And the words were barely out of
her mouth when this voice boos
out from behind, "You
talking to us, lady?"
And I turned around and
there's a guy sitting behind me
who I would best describe as
Santa Claus with an attitude.
Older white guy, big white beard,
white hair, wearing overalls
and a flannel shirt with a
car magazine in his hand.
Yeah, you're chuckling
like I did, you know.
I kind of got him pegged, right?
So I went about my
business on my computer
until it was time to
get on the plane.
It comes time to get on the plane.
I get down to my seat and lo and
behold, who's sitting next to me
but angry Santa Claus [laughter].
>> Oh yeah.
>> Howard Ross: So we did the nod.
Travelers know what I mean.
You know and you kind of sit down.
We take off, go into
parallel plane mode.
I'm working on my computer.
He's reading his magazine.
We fly for a couple of hours until
it's time to do the initial descent
to New York City so
I closed my computer.
And travelers know this is
when airplane chat starts
because it's now safe to talk
to the person next to you.
You're not going to get stuck
in a two-hour conversation
with a lunatic, you know [laughter].
And so I turned to him and I say,
"So what takes you to New York?"
And he says, "I've got
a business meeting."
I said, "Really, what
are you doing?"
And he says, "I'm a radiologist."
So boom! There goes
that picture, you know.
So now, I was sort of nonplussed
and a little embarrassed.
And I said, "So what
kind of radiology?"
And he says, "Well, you
might be interested in this,"
because I was working on a deck
that I was going to be using
and he had clearly been, you
know, kind of catching glimpses.
He said, "We're studying the brain.
We're watching it on a functional
magnetic resonating image array
and we can actually determine
which parts of the brain responds
when people interact with
different kinds of people.
Yeah, exactly so he's studying the
very thing I'm the most interested
in [laughter].
And had I not pegged him as angry
Santa the car mechanic and talked
to him a little bit earlier,
I probably would have saved
myself months of research
on my book, so [laughter].
So I say that because I'm
not here to talk about you.
This is who we are as human
beings, every single one of us.
Now we each have different
aspects that we respond to,
different kinds of
people we respond to.
But this is fundamental to
who we are as human beings.
And it's important for us to
recognize that because if we look
at the background through
which we've seen diversity
and inclusion work over a
period of time, it really comes
from a very different angle.
I've been paid for doing this
work now for over 30 years.
I go back to the times some
of you remember when the kind
of diversity workshops we did
were with the two-by-four.
You know, you kind of beat
people over the head especially
if they look like this until at
some point they saw the error
of their ways.
It was always very cathartic
if they cried [laughter].
And then -- and then -- and then
people would sort of you know,
see the light and you would believe.
But what I began to
notice was when we talked
to those people a month later or two
months later, more times than not,
they would say, "Well,
that was fine.
Just don't make me
ever do it again."
It was a recipe for getting people
to watch out what not to do,
to be careful what not to say but
it wasn't a recipe for inclusion.
It wasn't a recipe
for truly engaging,
getting people to truly engage.
In fact, sometimes, it
had the opposite effect.
They had people be
even more tentative.
You talk about race.
I'm heading out of here because I
don't want to say the wrong thing
and get in trouble again.
So if we look at that, we can kind
of see that there is a paradigm
that we dealt with these issues of
diversity with for a long, long time
and it's this one -- this sort
of us versus them paradigm.
And as soon as an issue comes
up, we immediately put ourselves
into a particular position
that we've already established.
So if you think about something
like I know many people --
how many people remember
the incident that happened
with Skip Gates -- with the
Harvard history professor?
You remember the Beer Summit?
Right, so Professor Gates,
one of America's most notable
historians -- he's African-American.
He comes home from a trip to Asia.
He comes to his front door
in Cambridge, Massachusetts.
He's locked out so he breaks
a window so he can get in.
Police officers show up.
Something happens and he's arrested.
It becomes big -- you
know, big news.
The next morning, there's
his picture
of his mug shot on the morning news.
How many of us when we heard that
story already knew what happened?
You see what I mean?
Either we knew that
it was one more time
when it was a white police officer
treating an African-American
in a particular way or we knew,
if we were on the other side
of equation, one more time
when a public servant just
doing his job is called a racist
for no reason.
Whatever it is, we choose
sides and this is the nature
of this us-versus-them dynamic.
If you have any question
about this, by the way,
read the news this morning about
the president's speech last night.
Or better yet, watch MSNBC and
Fox News and you will wonder
if you were watching the
same speech [laughter].
Because most of the responses -- and
we have to acknowledge on all sides,
most of the responses we
were already ready for.
Those of us who, like the president,
were ready to agree
with what he said.
Those of us who don't like
the president were ready
to have all the excuses because we
no longer look at issues and think
about the issues that
come to determinations.
We come from our ideology
to those issues looking
for how we can be right.
And if we're going to move forward
with this issue, we need to be able
to look at the whole
dynamic that's here --
because what gets produced is what
I call a conversational network
of contention.
So this tension that we have
around talking about these issues
that makes it so painful and
frankly, for a lot of people,
so frightening to talk
about the issues.
And that's the background to which
we've historically done diversity
and inclusion work.
So when we look at it over a period
of time, we go back 30 to 40 years
when we -- when this movement
really took on in organizations --
mostly we were looking at coming
from a place of ignorance.
You know, at the start, people
didn't know there were issues.
So we had [inaudible] from that into
compliance and affirmative action.
So we have to stop things
that are happening badly.
Fix some things that happened badly.
Get more people engaged
who have been left
out so hire representation.
Make sure people don't discriminate
so we have laws to protect people
so that they're not
discriminated against.
And ultimately then get to this
place of what people call tolerance.
Now I don't know about you but I've
never aspired just to be tolerated.
So I've never particularly
liked that word.
But the metaphor I use for
it is it's sort of like
in the old days before the wellness
movement hit back in the 1980s.
You would go to a doctor and the job
of the doctor was to get you unsick.
And I mean very rarely in
the 1960s and the 1970s,
if you went to a doctor,
did they say,
"Tell me about your
exercise program.
Tell me about what you're eating."
You know, they just didn't do that.
That wasn't their job.
You came in with an illness.
They made you unsick.
Then at some point, we realized
there's a whole another side
to the whole wellness continuum.
And that is how can you actually
live a life that has you be well
like to exercise and to eat
well and to manage your stress
and all the things that we now
know are so important to us
and doctors now talk to us about?
Well, similarly, we found
out that this is only --
this part of the equation
only gets us representation.
But what it doesn't do is help
us really engage with each other.
How do we manage that diversity
so we know how it's affecting us?
And ultimately, how do we have full
inclusion and cultural competency?
And as a result of that, we can see
that despite all of our efforts,
despite the millions of dollars that
have been spent and the, you know,
hundreds of thousands or
millions of people who have gone
through training programs or
the laws that have been passed.
We still have any number of examples
that we see on a daily basis
where people are treated
differentially based on race,
based on sexual orientation,
based on gender,
based on any number
of different things.
Now we know, this has been a
subject of enormous research.
How it is that the mind does this?
I want to share just a handful
of the literally 1200 studies
that have been done in the last 10
years alone on unconscious bias.
So this one is a pretty
interesting one.
Arin Reeves is a researcher
in Chicago.
She went to groups of law firms
and she gave partners a memo
that was written by a man named
Thomas Meyer, they were told.
It had 22 intentional errors
that were written into the memo.
Half of the lawyers were told that
Thomas Meyer was white and half
of them were told that he was black.
When they were told that he was
white, they found on average --
or they rated it on
average 4.1 out of 5.
They found on average
10.2 of the errors
and you can see some of
the things they said.
He has potential.
He has good analytical
skills, generally a good writer
but needs to work on some things.
When they were told that
Thomas Meyer was black,
they found 40% more errors,
rated him a 3.2 instead of a 4.1
and this Thomas Meyer needs a
lot of work, average at best
and I can't believe he went to NYU.
Nothing different about the resumes
except the race that they were told
of the name of the
person who wrote them.
And this one at Columbia
University and NYU and Wharton,
they tracked emails and found that
women have 35% more emails ignored
and almost 60% more
meetings declined.
Now this one for me is
particularly interesting
because when we send
emails out into the world
and they don't get responded to,
none of know whether, you know,
it's because a person is
a terrible communicator
or whether they're just
not listening to us.
We all know privately we
have a little pecking order
of emails, don't we?
You know, we have the emails.
We'll get to them.
When we get to them and then we have
emails so we got to take a break
to see what's somebody's
sending us [laughter].
You know, the people
who are important to us?
So when you look at these, these are
things that we would never know and
yet obviously has a huge impact
on people staying in the loop,
people getting engaged with
things, people being able
to have their work valued and
input, all these kinds of things.
Accent is another one.
Researchers at the
University of Chicago
and Tel-Aviv University found
that we believe people more
when they have accents
similar to ours and less
different than ours,
with one exception --
anybody want to guess?
>> British.
>> Howard Ross: That's
right, the British.
That's right.
We think people with British accents
not only make better movie villains
but they're also smarter [laughter].
One of our clients in
New York City has that.
There's a guy who works
there from Liverpool
where the Beatles come from.
And Liverpool is a very blue-collar
town so they speak a form
of Cockney there that is
called Scouse, I think.
And I think that's the
way it's pronounced.
And it's sort of a -- what he said,
he was told growing up,
it was gutter English.
So he says, "Whenever I fly back
to visit my family in Liverpool
and then come back to the States,
I feel myself getting
smarter every mile I fly."
[Laughter] Weight is another one.
Researchers of at least four
different universities have found
that doctors discriminated against
patients who were overweight.
Spent less time with them,
less follow up on protocols,
in every way less patient service.
They also found -- other researchers
found at Johns Hopkins University,
the patients do the
same thing with doctors.
That if a doctor is
overweight, they tend to listen
to the doctors' instructions less
and evaluate their treatment less.
And then this is one I did.
I have an artificial knee and so
every time I go through scanning
like downstairs, you know, I have to
get -- you know, do the wand thing.
So right, what I began to notice
was I was in airports that it seemed
like I was going through slower
when I was in casual clothing
than when I was dressed
in a business suit.
So it turns out, I did my own
study over a period of a year.
And it turns out about 47% faster
when I'm different clothing.
And most of us know
that this is true,
that appearance changes
the way we relate --
that we're related to whether it's
because of clothing or piercings
or tattoos or hairstyles or
age, any number of things.
And this is my new favorite.
When this came out of the National
Academy of Sciences just last year,
they studied the 47 most damaging
hurricanes over the last 60 years
and they found -- to see
if there was any pattern
in the fatalities associated
with gender name of hurricanes.
And they found that it turns
out that hurricanes named
after women kill roughly
twice as many people
as hurricanes named
after men [laughter].
Now lest you think this
has something to do
with hell hath no fury like
a woman scorned [laughter],
it's got nothing to do with that.
>> Oh, I'm not sure.
>> Howard Ross: What the
research [laughter] --
what the researchers found at the
National Academy of Sciences --
this is not some touchy-feely
organization --
the reason is, believe it or not, is
because people take hurricanes named
after men more seriously and
therefore prepare for them more.
Now how insane is that?
Can you -- that's right, absolutely.
Can you imagine the conversation?
So Leslie comes up
to me and she says --
I just choose Leslie because
we're old friends and I said --
so she comes up to me and
she says, "Hey, Howard.
There's a hurricane coming!"
I said, "Really?
What its name?"
She says, "Hurricane Mary."
I say, "Oh, don't worry.
It's a girl."
[Laughter] This is how crazy we are.
And I could go and I could
give you a list of studies
about virtually every
aspect of human identity.
And we have a study that shows that
people are biased based on that.
Now, you know, we're
laughing at this one
but obviously the same dynamic
occurs when a police officer walks
up to a young man in the
street and has a reaction
that this young man is more
dangerous than another young man.
I better pull my gun
out for this young man.
I better be on high
alert for this young man.
And this young man
ends up shot or dead.
It shows up seriously when
somebody comes in for an interview
and I listen to them
just differently
than somebody else as
we saw in that video.
They say the same things.
They have the same kind of resume.
They appear all the same
and yet for some reason,
this person resonates with me more.
I feel more comfortable with them.
I choose them.
So all of this is happening
all the time around us.
And, you know, what our
studies show is that very little
of it happens out of intention.
I mean, there are people out
there who are hateful and hurtful.
There's no question about it.
But as my good friend Brett
Pelham who's a researcher
at the National Science
Foundation said, "At some --
at some level, all bias
is unconscious bias."
Even the biases that we consciously
have now have been unconsciously fed
by the various things that we've
learned throughout our lives.
We weren't conscious about it
when we were three years old
and that being a boy, if I
picked up my sister's doll
and my mom slapped me
on the hand and said,
"Only sissies play with dolls."
And all of a sudden,
that choice shows
up as homophobia 15 years later.
So we want to look at this.
And what I want to do is
look at with you a little bit
that behind a curtain, it
is why does this happen?
How does it happen?
And then ultimately I want to
leave you with some thoughts
about the things that we're
discovering we can do about this
because we do have something
to say about our biases.
We can't eliminate bias but we
can learn to navigate them better.
We can learn to mitigate
the impact on our lives.
And then I will save some time, by
the way, at the end for questions.
So if you have questions, you want
to, you know, kind of make a note
of them or jot them down.
I will save about 15
minutes hopefully
at the end so we can engage in it.
But I'm actually willing
for any of you who would
like to stay along a little bit
later than one o'clock to try
to stick around for
a little bit longer.
So let's start with this question.
How much do we really know?
[ Music ]
>> Clearly, somebody in this
room murdered Lord Smythe
who at precisely 3:34 this
afternoon was brutally bludgeoned
to death with a blunt instrument.
I want each of you to tell me your
whereabouts at precisely the time
that this dastardly deed took place.
>> I was polishing the
brass in the master bedroom.
>> I was buttering his lordship's
scones below stairs, sir.
>> I was planting my
petunias in the potting shed.
>> Constable, arrest Lady Smythe!
>> But, but how did you know?
>> Madam, as any horticulturist
will tell you,
one does not plant
petunias until May is out.
Take her away.
>> Come on.
>> It's just a matter
of observation.
The real question is
how observant were you?
>> And action.
>> Clearly, somebody in this
room murdered Lord Smythe,
who at precisely 3:34 this
afternoon was brutally bludgeoned
to death with a blunt instrument.
I want each of you to tell me your
whereabouts at precisely the time
that this dastardly deed took place.
>> I was polishing the
brass in the master bedroom.
>> I was buttering his lordship's
scones below stairs, sir.
>> I was planting my
petunias in the potting shed.
>> Constable, arrest Lady Smythe!
>> Howard Ross: Now how many
of us have seen this happen?
This, by the way -- one of a series
of videos that they did in London
to make people more aware
of bicycle riders --
like the drivers to make
more bicycle riders.
How many of you have been in
a meeting, something happens.
Some interaction between people
and you walk out and you're saying
to yourself, "I can't believe that."
And somebody else says,
"What are you talking about?"
And has that -- had
that ever happened?
No. Well, it particularly
happens to, you know,
a particular group of people.
We notice that people are listened
to differently depending
upon the group their in.
Sometimes that's by status,
organizational status.
We listen to management maybe
more than non-management.
We listen to people from
our department differently
than we listen to people
from other departments.
Sometimes, it's because
of an identity factor --
race, gender, something like that.
We tend to value people more
without realizing it very much
like [inaudible] in that video.
And yet when we look at these
pictures, we can see all
of these things are happening.
All of these changes right in
front of our eyes and you knew
to be looking for something.
It wasn't like something
just popped upon the screen.
You know what we're
here to talk about.
And you know I said, "Do we really
see the world like we think we do
and yet still we don't see it?"
This is occurring all the time.
This is a phenomenon
that psychologists call
selective attention.
And there's been a tremendous
amount of research around this.
For example, there's a
researcher named Trafton Drew
at Harvard Medical School who sent
out a picture of a lung scanner.
It was actually a lung scan that
he sent out to radiologists.
He asked the radiologists
to look for cancer nodes
which are very, very tiny obviously.
Embedded in the lung
scan is a picture
of a gorilla 50 times the
size of a cancer node.
Fifty times the size -- 83% of
the radiologists didn't see it.
They were looking so
carefully for this
that they couldn't
see this [laughter].
Any of you have children
and asked them to go
to the closet to look for something?
You know what I'm talking
about [laughter], right?
That's selective attention
at its best [laughter].
Now this doesn't only
impact how we see.
It also impacts how we hear.
So I'm going to do
another little experiment.
Folks on this side of the room,
in just a moment I want
you to close your eyes.
I'm not going to let them
take your stuff, don't worry.
And folks over here, I want
you to watch the screen.
I'm going to show you all a
five-second video and I'm going
to ask you what you hear, okay?
So close your eyes over here.
Here we go.
>> Ba-ba, ba-ba, ba-ba.
>> Howard Ross: Good,
open your eyes.
So if you heard ba-ba,
please raise your hands.
If you heard something like
da-da or ga-ga, raise your hands.
Or a vowel sound, anything other
than ba-ba, raise your hands.
Now how does that happen?
Very odd, right.
I'm going to play it again.
This time, you could open and
close your eyes at intervals.
You'll actually hear it
change right before your eyes.
>> Ba-ba, ba-ba, ba-ba.
>> Wow.
>> Howard Ross: Now aside
from being way cool,
what does this teach us [laughter]?
We actually hear with our
eyes more than we realize.
In this case, it happens because
the video is of him saying ga-ga
but the voiceover is
of him saying ba-ba.
You actually hear what he
said with your eyes closed.
Over here, the brain plays
a little trick on us.
It has to deal with the dissonance
between what we're seeing
and what we're hearing so it
usually morphs into a D sound.
For some people, a little bit
of an L or a little bit of a G.
But the point is, it's a different
sound even though the sound that's
playing is the same.
Now this can happen in
lots of different ways.
For example, in many of us,
you've seen it happen this way.
Sorry, this is [inaudible].
>> We have got to cut
costs, people, ideas.
>> Well, we could open
an account on fedex.com.
>> We have got to cut
costs, people, ideas.
>> Well, we could open an
account on fedex.com to save 10%
on online express shipping.
>> Okay, how about this?
We open an account of fedex.com.
We save 10% on online
express shipping.
>> But you just said
the same thing I said.
Only you did this.
>> No, I did this.
It makes all the difference.
>> Bingo!
>> That's good.
>> That's right on the nose.
>> Yeah.
>> Really expressive ideas.
>> Howard Ross: There's something
nobody notices at 10 minutes later.
It's a eureka moment when
the man does it, you know.
As my friend, Sukhvinder Singh Obhi,
a brain scientist at Canada says,
"Our brains seem to have evolved to
be good enough most of the time."
So we want to look at this a
little bit because this is really
at the core of what bias is.
You know, how many of you when
you hear the word bias tend
to think of it in negative terms?
Can you hear it?
Yeah. In fact, bias is neither
inherently positive or negative.
It is simply a function of
the mind that's designed
to help us quickly chart how
to deal with a circumstance.
And why would we have that
function, do you think?
>> Survival?
>> It's evolutionary.
>> Howard Ross: Yeah, for
survival, exactly right.
Twenty thousand years ago, we see a
group of people by the waterhole --
we had to determine instantly
whether it was them or us.
If we made the wrong
decision, we got killed.
So as a result of that,
we have a tendency
to spot these things very quickly.
Now we know from research
that we first spot race
because it's the most
visible identifier.
Things like gender, we may be
more hard wired to see gender
because of course, times you
know, thousands of years ago,
we lived mostly with people
who are of the same race.
Very rarely encountered
people of opposite races.
But nonetheless, we spot race first.
And sometimes, this could
be very helpful to us
to spot a bias and
sometimes you can't.
If I walk up to one of you with
a knife in my hand like this,
you don't look up and
say, "I wonder what it is
and it's going to do with it?"
[Laughter] You know, you quickly get
into defensive mode
and it saves your life.
We have a bias against that.
But obviously, when it involves
somebody on the street and a gun,
it can have horrible consequences.
When it involves somebody
in a job interview,
it can have terrible
professional consequences.
So the phenomenon could be
either positive or negative.
It can help or hurt us.
But when we're not aware of it,
it has dangerous consequences.
And by the way, what do you call
biases when you agree to them
and even write them all down?
That's all qualifications are.
Now I'm not saying
qualifications are a bad thing.
They're valuable.
It makes it easier than having
to interview all of the tens
of thousands of people who probably
apply for jobs here, for example.
You couldn't possibly
interview all of them.
So we create qualifications.
So we say, for example,
college degree.
So toss out Steve Jobs.
Toss out Bill Gates.
Toss out Mark Zuckerberg, you know.
We have to be careful because when
we create these qualifications
without realizing, we're also
limiting ourselves to see the people
who follow the most
traditional path.
And there are lots of different
examples of how that shows up.
But I want to talk for just a
moment about what we're discovering
about why the brain
functions in this way.
So if you imagine, we see something
in front of us, some person
or circumstance and immediately,
what happens is and we know this now
because we can wire the brain
on functional magnetic
resonating imagery and we can see
which parts of the brain function.
Now we needed to go to what Daniel
Kahneman, great psychologist,
Nobel Prize winner,
calls our fast brain.
This is the limbic system.
If I use my hand as a brain model,
imagine this is the profile.
The limbic system is
in where my thumb --
actually, it would be
better if I had two thumbs
but that would be a
little weird [laughter].
That if I had -- that's
where the limbic system is.
The amygdala, the hippocampus,
the hypothalamus --
these are the parts of the brain
that quickly spot what's going on,
try to figure out very
quickly what it is.
It's like going to a file cabinet
and decide what's the action to it.
And so if I take this and
so -- is Bob, is that it?
Yeah, if I throw this at Bob,
he's not going to say, "Oh,
what happens when it gets here?"
You know, his hand will
shoot up instinctively.
It's a protection mechanism.
And it can save our lives.
You're driving in the morning and
the car stops short in front of you.
You see those taillights going.
You don't say to yourself,
"What's the best thing to do now?"
Or you'd be in their back seat.
Your foot hits the brake before
you get a chance to think about it.
This is where the heart of a lot
of our core stereotypes come from.
Quick assessment to that person.
Quick association -- put
myself into friend or foe mode.
And we're particularly
sensitive to foe.
We look first to eliminate
foe before we see friend.
So we can see this
again in the brain.
It takes about 20% more
brain energy, fluid,
et cetera to see something
friendly than it has
to see something negative
because the brain wants
to make sure it's safe before
it will allow things in.
And this is why, of course, the
instinctive reactions that happen
with people in tense
situations are really challenging
because what happens is the
amygdala, the basic fear center
of the brain gets charged and
you have an amygdala hijacking.
It takes over.
Right now, we have a collective
amygdala hijacking happening
in our culture around Islamophobia.
People are reacting in ways that
are completely contrary to anything
that they would have
rationally thought or believed --
doing things that completely
inappropriate.
I'm not talking now about political
ideologies and thoughtful processes
about what's the best
to handle this.
I'm talking about that
fear reaction.
When somebody comes into an
airport, gets on an airplane
and a woman with a hijab walks in.
And somebody's looking
where she sits.
That's the fear reaction.
Most of us have felt those
at times and we're all --
we're even embarrassed by them.
When we see it, we feel them
but we can't help it just
like I was embarrassed by my
reaction to angry Santa Claus.
It wasn't like a reaction I chose.
I was in -- my actions
had [inaudible].
I said to myself afterwards, "You've
been doing this work for 30 years?"
I actually went to my first Civil
Rights meeting 50 years ago.
How long do you take before
you get it out of your system?
But the truth is we don't
get it out of our system?
We do, however, have the capacity
for more thoughtful thinking,
at least in our slow brain,
in the prefrontal cortex,
this part of the brain.
The red part in this
picture you see --
the most remarkable
part of the human brain,
four to five times larger than
any other animal per body size,
two to three times more active.
It gives us the capability of
what we call metacognition,
the ability to watch
ourselves think.
This is where we have thoughts like,
"What made me think about that?"
Any of you who have done any kind
of personal development work,
any kind of therapy work -- it's all
about developing the prefrontal
ability to watch ourselves.
This is where we see, "Oh yeah,
I know my mother triggers me.
Let me go take a breath
so that I don't react."
I know I'm about to wring my
kid's neck because once again,
their homework is a mess.
I take a breath and
I settle myself down.
This is the part of the brain that
allows us to socialize ourselves
so that we're not just
reaction machines,
robots dealing with each other.
And it's going on all the time.
All the time.
Now, how that shows up is
over the course of our lives,
we developed sort of an
internal book of rules.
So let's step back from
behind for just a minute.
So if I walk up to [inaudible].
Now how did you learn to do that?
>> By socializing.
>> Howard Ross: Exactly.
This is the social cue
we had so [inaudible]?
>> Travis.
>> Howard Ross: Travis.
So how did the handshake
feel, Travis?
>> Yours?
>> Howard Ross: Yeah.
>> Light.
>> Howard Ross: Yeah, light.
So I shook Travis' hand much
softer than we normally do
in American business
environment which is more
like a wrestling match,
you know [laughter].
Your description was
actually pretty tame.
Most people would say weak, fishy,
you know, all these comments.
But how many of us -- how many of us
have heard somebody say at one point
or another, "If somebody shakes
my hand like that at the beginning
of an interview, forget it.
The interview's over."
Now think about how insane that is.
In about a third of the world,
that's the normal way
to shake hands.
>> Wow.
>> Howard Ross: I could
have a disability.
I could be recovering from
an injury or have an injury.
And yet, what are we looking for?
We're looking for the shortcuts.
And so we learn this book of
rules throughout our lives.
You learn certain ways that
we're supposed to be and we --
and this creates a schema.
It creates a frame of -- a brain
frames what we see and draws
out that which we are interested in.
So watch a shoe shine person in
the airport the next time you're
in the airport or the train station.
And as they're walking -- as
you're watching people walk
down the hallway, watch
what they're looking at.
What do you think they're
looking at?
Shoes, exactly.
They're looking for the
person with dirty shoes
so they can say, "Do
you need a shine?"
If you ask them what they see,
you see three men, two
women and the child.
They see three loafers, two
Florsheims and a pair of sneakers.
And they often wouldn't even
be able to tell you anything
about the person because they've
never looked above the knee.
This is the way a schema works.
Let me show you.
Take a look at this picture and see
if you can identify anything
recognizable in this picture.
Anybody see anything?
Yeah, what do you see?
>> I see a dog.
>> Howard Ross: A dog.
Okay, anybody else?
>> A cow.
>> Howard Ross: A cow, okay.
Somebody saw the cow.
Well, let me make it -- there
is a cow in the picture.
I'll make it easier for you.
I'll superimpose it.
Okay, so can everybody see
the cow now [laughter]?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, so every -- so everybody --
anybody who doesn't see the cow?
Okay, let me quickly
point it out here.
In here's -- okay, right.
Excuse me.
Now I'm going to remove these
-- oh, the superimposed picture.
Go back to the original
and tell me now
if you could avoid seeing the cow.
Right? The thing that was
invisible just a moment ago --
now, you can't not see.
If I came in next week,
immediately you would see the cow
because your schema has changed.
Now, if schema can be impacted
by something like shiny shoes
or a silly game like this, how can
it not be impacted by these bodies,
these identities we
have our lives in?
Now as men, we see a different world
than women -- as people of color,
a different world than white people.
Because our schema impacts
that which we see and
that which we don't.
And so we're sensitive
to certain things.
We're alert about certain things.
We're looking for certain
things or completely oblivious
to certain things which is why
it's so frustrating sometimes
to have these conversations.
"Why are you making such
a big deal out of that?"
somebody will say.
Because it happens to me every day.
You're just not seeing it --
particularly the micro behaviors.
Now we sometimes call them micro
inequities, micro advantages.
Some people are using the term
micro aggressions these days.
The little things that
have an impact
but don't seem very big
in and of themselves.
You know, if somebody
walks up to you
and you give them your full
attention versus another person
who walks up to you
and you tell them
to go ahead while you're
multitasking on your phone.
By the way, how many
people here pride yourselves
at being multitaskers?
Anybody else besides me?
You know there's bad news, right?
>> Yeah [laughter].
>> Howard Ross: We can't.
The brain doesn't multitask.
I mean, it can if you're
doing some kind
of a mindless activity
like a repetitive task.
Like if you're -- if you knit and
you've been knitting for years,
your hands knit by themselves
or something like that.
But mostly, what we call
multitasking is serial tasking.
We're looking at this, this, this.
We're kind of going like this which
is why when we're in those meetings,
they say, for everybody sitting
at the meeting like this looking
at their phones as if nobody knows
what they're doing [laughter]?
And then you walk out of the room.
What's the first thing
they usually say?
What did they say about
that [laughter]?
Because we only see about 70%.
So schema gives us a
particular background
and the background frames what we
see and becomes self-fulfilling.
We gather information to support
our already point of view.
This is what we were
seeing this morning
with the pundits looking
at the speech.
I already believe that
the president is good.
I already believe the
president is bad.
Therefore, I'll cherry pick the
speech and take out the points
that prove my point and ignore
the things that maybe iffy.
And I'll make that case or even
sometimes take the same piece
of data and use it for two
completely different purposes.
And we do this with
people, of course.
Yeah, somebody who you
like who works with you
and they screw some
things up and you know,
their excuses make a lot of sense.
Somebody you don't like so much,
it's just one more
excuse [laughter].
And this is effective and I say
that definitively because as I said,
we have over a thousand
studies in 10 years alone.
It is affected by people's identity.
It's affected by who that person
is and what that person is.
Now, so that background
becomes self-reinforcing.
Now just to give you a
sense of the comparison,
if the slow brain capacity
is roughly the size
of a gallon milk jug, the fast
brain is like the Milky Way.
Literally hundreds of thousands
of times more fast brain reactions
than slow brain reactions.
We are robots basically
walking around pretending
like we're sentient beings.
>> Yeah.
>> Howard Ross: Now ironically,
it's only when we accept
that about ourselves
that we actually have the
opportunity for consciousness.
When we realize how automatic
we are and we begin watching it,
then we have an opportunity
to disengage it at times.
Otherwise, we go around
making stuff up about people.
So I want you to imagine
for a minute.
You've got a son or a daughter.
You've got a son or a
daughter and they call you
and they say, "Mom,
Dad, I'm in love.
I found the guy of my dreams.
He's the one and I can't wait to
bring him home at Thanksgiving
and introduce him to you."
Well, you're kind of anxious, right?
You want to see this guy.
So you go on their Facebook page
or whatever social media
you tend to prefer.
And you see pictures of them with
two men -- this one or this one.
Who are you hoping for?
[ Laughter ]
Right? Well, as it turns out,
this guy is John Fetterman.
He's the mayor of Braddock,
Pennsylvania, a candidate for Senate
in the State of Pennsylvania
right now.
A master's degree in
public policy from Harvard.
Served in AmeriCorps and got
international media attention
for the amazing way he transformed
the old steel town that Braddock is
and he turned it into
a thriving community.
He actually works with
other communities
to help them do the same thing.
Amazing guy if it's [inaudible].
This is Ted Bundy,
the serial killer.
[ Laughter ]
And yet, we do this with
people all the time.
We spot people all the time.
We make stuff up about them.
You know, if you look around
the room for a minute.
Just let your eyes, don't let
it settle on any but just look
around the room for
a second [laughter].
And see what you make up
about who's the smart one,
who's the one that's
not so smart, you know.
Who's the one who's in the
leadership position or not?
Who's the one who looks
friendly or not so friendly?
scared or not so scared?
This is what we do with people.
We make these assessments
and then we act
in accordance with
those assessments.
And it's not only individual,
by the way.
It shows up in social groups too.
In fact, we're much more influenced.
What we're learning is we're much
more influenced by the groups
that we belong to than we
ever even thought possible.
Now most of us have heard
of Maslow's hierarchy.
Abraham Maslow created
this model in 1943,
core foundation model
of modern psychology.
Maslow said that there are
certain things that needs
that are more important
than other needs.
And you got to get your
physiological needs met then safety
and then we worry about
belongingness on up the chain.
It turns out that we're
discovering Maslow was wrong.
That belongingness is
actually the key human need.
And it makes sense
if we think about it
because what's the most vulnerable
time of a human being's existence?
Infancy, right?
The first two years of our lives,
we can't exist unless somebody --
unless we belong to somebody.
We literally will die.
Our first imprint is I exist
because he or she exists,
whoever our primary caretaker is.
And in fact, we know
that being excluded
from a group triggers
activity in the same regions
of the brain associated
with physical pain
which is why every time one of
these terrible incidents happen,
Sandy Hook, Columbine, Charleston,
what's the first word you
almost always hear used
to describe the individual?
>> Loner.
>> Howard Ross: Loner,
almost every time, right?
And it also contributes to
the fact that four times
as many gay teenagers commit
suicide because that same sense
of loneliness gets internalized,
even sometimes separating them
from their own -- separating
somebody from their own family.
But the behavior also leads -- this
phenomenon also leads to behavior
that sometimes it's
just downright funny.
>> The gentleman in the
elevator now is a candid star.
These folks who are entering --
the man with the white shirt,
the lady with the trench coat
and subsequently one other member
of my staff will face the rear
and you'll see how this man
and the trench coat woman --
[ Laughter ]
-- tried to maintain his
individuality [laughter].
And little by little --
[ Laughter ]
-- he looks at his watch but
he's really making an excuse
for turning just a little bit
more [laughter] to the wall.
Now we try it once again.
Here's the candid subject.
Here comes the Candid Camera staff.
Three of them at least [laughter].
And this man hasn't apparently
been in groups before.
[ Laughter ]
>> Howard Ross: We don't
do the same thing, right.
I mean, how many times have
you gone out in the evening?
[Inaudible] anything
to drink tonight
so everybody else orders
a glass of wine.
And now, what the heck,
I'll have it, you know.
Or more importantly, you come
into a calibration meeting.
You're evaluating an employee
and there are five of
you in the meeting.
And you come in really
high on the employee.
You're very positive about them.
But before you get to weigh in,
the other four people trash him
to all the terrible things about
this employee, why they're no good.
Then they say, "What do you think?"
And all of a sudden, you notice
you're a little bit more hesitant
with your praise, a little bit more
muted, if you even give it at all.
There's part of us that wants to go
along with the crowd and this is one
of the reasons why
workplace environments --
doing this work in
workplace environments can be
so valuable when it's done well.
Because you begin to
create a culture
in which people are supported
in making more conscious choice
and in thinking more carefully
about the decisions
they make around people.
But there is good news.
I promised you I will leave you
with some of the things we can do
about this because you
know, at this point,
a lot of times people are saying,
"Great, now you convinced me
that I can't believe anything I
think and I got biases about people
that I'm not even aware of.
Thank you very much
for that, right."
But there is good news and that is
that in fact, that there are ways
that we can consciously develop
the ability to be more mindful
of our decision-making,
be more thoughtful
about the things that influence us.
We've identified six
things in particular
because the unconscious
mind is quite malleable.
We've got a remarkable capacity
for what we call neuroplasticity
to rewire our brains.
The notion is that you can't teach
an old dog new tricks isn't even
true for dogs.
We're always learning new things.
I remember when my
stepfather who passed away
about a year-and-a-half ago now.
He was 83 when he learned
to use the internet.
And it was life altering for
him because now he could shop
for himself even though, you know,
he couldn't drive himself anymore.
He could send notes to
people and receive them.
I even taught him to Skype
so that he could, you know,
we could talk to him face-to-face.
It was life altering and at 83
years old, he learned to do it.
But he wasn't a techno
-- a technical guy.
It's just that you know, we
learn new things all the time.
So six ways -- the first is
by far, the most important.
And that is to recognize and
accept that we have bias.
That it's foundational to
have it as we see the world.
The question is not do we have bias?
The question is which are ours?
And every single person
in this room,
if you tell the truth, knows this.
We know that there are
certain people who are inclined
to like more than others.
We know that we go into that
party where there's nobody there
who we know and we make
a quick mental decision
as to who's the person we're
going to go up to talk to --
based on who looks
safer or more welcoming.
Based on what?
Who has looked safer, more
welcoming like that before?
We project onto that
circumstance what we've learned
in the past from our book of rules.
And the metaphor I like to use for
this is it's kind of like the clutch
in a standard transmission
automobile for those of you
who even remember standard
transmission automobiles.
When you step on the clutch,
the motor doesn't stop running.
The motor is still running.
It just disengaged
from running the car.
Similarly if I say to myself,
"Okay, I have a bias about this.
I better be careful about this."
When I've been talking or
interacting with that person,
I have a chance to separate.
I give an example for myself.
I had a young man come in to
do an interview a few years ago
for an administrative
position at our company.
And I've been a professional
musician for probably 30 years.
I don't do it so much anymore,
but for about 30 years
I played in bands.
And so I looked at his resume
and it says Berkeley School
of Music for two years.
And immediately my
whole body leaned in.
What do you play?
What kind of music do you play?
And then, you know, because I
happened to catch it this time.
Like I said, I missed it
with the guy in the airplane.
But this time, I happened
to catch it.
I said, "Wait a second.
You're not interviewing
a bass player.
You're interviewing an
administrative person."
So I actually said to
him, "You know what?
Let's hold off on that
conversation for now.
Maybe we'll talk about
that after the interview."
Come back to do the interview.
Now I'm not saying it would
have been perfect necessarily.
That it still might
not have influenced me
but I had a far greater chance than
what would have normally happened
if I was unconscious, which is I
would have spent 45 minutes talking
with him about music and
then I would have said,
"Now let me ask you these
questions so that I can hire you."
[Laughter] Because I already
heard his bass playing behind my
guitar [laughter].
The second, in order to do that,
we have to develop the
capacity to observe ourselves.
The metaphor that I like to use is
to put a flashlight on ourselves.
To watch ourselves in action.
Mostly the way we relate
to the world is we look
at what's going on out there.
And we figure out why we're --
why the thing out there
is causing us trouble.
We have very little
attention on what --
how are we responding
to what's up there?
What is that triggering in us?
Who is that person reminding us of?
Are there certain circumstances
where we notice
that we get charged
more than others?
Now that's where we begin to see
ourselves in action and that's
where we begin to shift
ourselves in action.
Now my wife, one morning says to me,
"Would you mind taking
out the trash?"
Now I have no problem
taking out the trash.
I even do it myself
sometimes, you know.
But for some reason,
I just got irritated
and I didn't even know why,
you know, at the moment.
And then I stopped for a second.
I looked and I said,
"Why am I irritated?"
And then I realized.
At that moment I saw -- I was seven
years old and she was my mother.
My mother and I used to have
righteous battles over the trash.
Some of you remember those
kinds of things or have them
with your own children, right?
And at that moment, something about
the way she said it or something
about that circumstance reminded
me of my mother giving me stuff
about not taking out the trash.
And so I left.
I said, "Sure, Mom.
I'll take it out."
And given that we -- we
both do this work together.
She knew exactly what I meant and
laughed and that was the end of it.
There's something liberating
about this.
In order to do this, the
third thing is we have
to practice what I call
constructive uncertainty.
Turn some of our exclamation
points into question marks.
Is that person really that way or
might I be seeing them that way?
That's a huge distinction.
And one of the ways we do this
is by slowing ourselves down.
The breath is really valuable.
I've been working with
police officers around this.
And one of the things I'm
teaching them is to use the breath
when they're on to
emergent crime scenes.
If you just simply do
some deep breathing,
it slows down the process
a little bit.
It doesn't put them -- so I'm
not talking about just sitting
in cross positions saying
"Om," or anything like that.
I'm just talking about -- the
reason it happens, by the way,
there's a physiological
reason for this.
That the part of your brain
that you need to use in order
to consciously slow
down your breathing,
to deepen your breathing -- when you
say, "Okay, take a deeper breath,"
is your prefrontal cortex.
You go out of your limbic
system when you do that
and your prefrontal area
now is what's in charge.
The prefrontal area is the
slower part of your brain.
They may get to the emergent crime
scene and for a split second longer,
wait before they pull that trigger.
For a split second longer,
consider what they're doing.
Because you know, I have tremendous
-- I want to make it really clear,
I have tremendous compassion
for what police officers
have to deal with as well.
You put yourself in the situation
where in moments you have
to make a decision like to
cost somebody else their life.
It could cost you your career.
You could be the next public pariah.
And yet, if you wait too
long, you could be killed.
I mean, I don't know anybody here
but I'm not signing up for that job.
But at the same time, we know the
consequences of it not going well.
So we're trying to
teach people to be able
to be more conscious about that.
Rollo May, a great psychologist
said, "Freedom is the capacity
to pause between stimulus
and response."
Another one that we found that
really makes a difference is
to engage with others and expose
yourself to counter stereotypes.
In other words, positive
examples of people
who normally have negative
stereotypes around.
So pictures on the
wall make a difference.
Things like Black History
Month still matter
because they give us
positive stereotypes.
Now it would be a lot better
if the other 11 months were White
History Month and if we didn't,
you know -- if we didn't
continually reinforce that,
if we really embedded it more.
But nonetheless, these kinds
of things really matter
because they give us
those counter stereotypes.
Spending time with
people makes a difference.
Meeting people from other cultures,
identities, races, racial groups,
sexual orientation
makes the difference.
You know, in a sad way, you know,
one of the things we're
finding that's in the research
that behind the acceleration
of rights
for LGBT people today
ironically was the AIDS epidemic.
Because what did the
AIDS epidemic do?
It made it obvious that certain
people who people loved too
in their family, all of a sudden,
their sexual orientation
became more apparent.
We never knew Rock Hudson
was gay until he got AIDS.
That's not to suggest, by the
way, that all people have AIDS.
We know that they're not.
But the point is in the early
days, that it had that impact.
Now, for one thing to not
like those gay people,
it's another thing entirely
to not like my son Bobby,
or my cousin Johnny, or
my sister-in-law Sally.
When it becomes personal,
it's very different.
And then the last one is to
establish ways to get feedback,
to create relationships so people
can come up to us and say, "Look,
you may not have intended
anything about this
but let me tell you how
your behavior affected me."
Now for those of us who are in
power in leadership positions,
it's critically important
that we recognize that we have
to set the tone for that.
We have to be the ones who put
ourselves out there and be open
to feedback because otherwise
people project all of their --
you know, authority
figures from their lives.
If you had a father who didn't
like feedback from you --
or very few fathers do, I
find, you know [laughter].
I'm speaking as somebody with
four children [laughter].
Then you may be hesitant
even if the boss says, "Sure,
tell me what you're thinking,"
because what we tack on to the end
of that sentence is even if it
costs you your job, you know.
But creating a flow back and forth
where we can give each other
feedback actually creates a way
for us to see ourselves
in other people's eyes.
And it could be incredibly
valuable in this process.
Now I want to spend just the last
minute or two talking about systems
because you're working in
an organization and we know
that we can change systems.
In 1970, 5% of the musicians
in the major orchestras
in the world were women.
In 1980, there was only 12.
Still only 12% even after 15 years
of modern women's movement
-- the resurgence of it.
The number is now over 40%.
What happened?
They put in a whole range
of structures and systems
that changed the way
they did auditions.
The first one was they began to
advertise for auditions rather
than simply to invite
people to them.
It used to be the conductor would
say, "Get the second chair violin
for Philadelphia to
come and audition."
Now what they do is ask or
advertise them in trade magazines
so people can show up and audition.
The second thing they
did is they started
to use panels rather
than individuals.
The conductor used to make
the choice individually.
Now what they do is they
have panels of people
so that you have different
points of view
and the more diverse
the panel, the better.
So you can get different
points of view, you know,
what did we think rather
than what did I think?
And the most important
thing they did was
that they changed the fundamental
structure of the audition itself.
They began to have people
audition behind screens and walking
out on rugs so that people could
no longer see the musician.
They could no longer hear
the shoes of the musician.
All they could hear was the music.
This was, by the way, for
those of you who are fans.
This is where The
Voice came from on TV.
And what they found was it
fundamentally changed the way
to music.
So when you're changing a system,
it's not enough just
to do individual work.
Yes, we want to look at education
because education is important.
And we're not talking about
a quick talk like this.
I'm talking about actually spending
some time understanding these
dynamics and how we
respond to these dynamics.
The second is to create
priming techniques because even
if you have the best
training program in the world,
if you don't do a performance
review until four months from now,
how much are you going to remember?
So you might have a
little tool that you use.
We call them performance
support tools.
Before I do a performance
review, I take two minutes
to watch this little video clip
or I read this sheet of paper.
I answer these questions so that I'm
reminded to pay attention to some
of the dynamics that might show
up in the performance review.
It makes a huge difference.
The third -- whoops.
The third one is to change some
of our systems and structures
like do we interview
people in the same way?
Maybe we will shift
that a little bit.
Maybe we have panel interviews
rather than individual interviews.
Maybe we send the interview
questions out to people a couple
of days early because that balances
out English as a second language
or introversion versus extroversion.
You know, maybe we'd be sure
that we interview people
on all the same circumstances
because you interview
one person fresh
when you're nine o'clock
in your office.
The second person in the cafeteria
at noon and the third person
over Skype -- you're conducting
three different interviews.
Now so there are things that we
can do structurally to change that.
Actually for those of you who buy
the book, in the appendix there,
I have 16 pages of ideas
for those kinds of things.
And then finally, we need
to establish a system
of accountability.
We need to keep track of
these things at every stage
because what we notice is
by the time we usually --
for most people and most
organizations, we have one metric
for diversity which
is how many are there.
But if we really look at the system,
we see well how many
applied for jobs?
How many were offered jobs?
How many accepted jobs?
Now how many are successful
after six months?
We could begin to see when the
breakdown in the system happens.
So there are things
we can do about this.
Yes, it exists.
It's inevitability for human
beings but there are things
that we could do about it.
And I'd like to end
with this picture.
This is a picture of an
Aspen forest in Colorado,
because at the essence
this is what I'm learning
about who we are as human beings.
You know, we look at these forests.
Some of you, I'm sure, have
seen them if you travel
to that part of the country.
And they're majestic.
Thousands of acres of these
ramrod straight trees.
They go up 80 to 100
feet tall, incredible.
Do you know the interesting
thing about the Aspen trees?
They're not individual trees at all.
The Aspen forest has the largest
intact organisms in the world.
They're connected by
common root systems.
The way they grow is that one
tree [inaudible] around another
and another and another and another.
The largest one in Northern
Utah has 80,000 trees.
It's one plant.
One plant.
For me, it's a perfect metaphor
for who we are as human beings.
We act like we're each
different but in reality,
when we understand
our psychomechanisms,
the way we think -- we're actually
more similar than we think we are.
We check different material,
different life stories
that we process differently
but we actually process --
excuse me, different content to
process but we actually process
that information very
much the same way.
And if we can really get that,
then instead of saying,
"Why are you that way?"
We could say, "Why
are you that way?"
So there's a difference
between fear and curiosity.
And that conversation we
can create environments
in which everybody can thrive.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us loc.gov.